- There are new developments
and still a ton of misinformation.
So on this Wednesday checkup
Coronavirus, episode two.
(soft music)
Right off the bat I have to say again,
we should not be panicking
alert not anxious
is the mindset I want you to take.
Just like I said in the
first Coronavirus video,
last week.
There's been a ton of
headlines with the WHO,
declaring a global health emergency.
The CDC declaring a national emergency
here in the United States.
But all of those are not reasons to panic.
I'm gonna be explaining what
each of those things mean,
what they mean for you, things you can do
to keep yourself safe and put this whole
Coronavirus thing into perspective.
As to the way we see it
now and how the situation
is gonna expand and change.
Today's date is February 3rd 2020.
The reason I tell you that
is because the numbers
are gonna change moving forward.
And I want you to know
when this video was filmed.
We're also gonna learn
more about this virus.
We're gonna learn how it spreads.
We're gonna learn more
about its genetic makeup
how it came about so I want you to be
as up to date as possible.
I may make another Coronavirus video
for next week's Wednesday checkup.
But we'll see how that situation evolves.
Let's start off this
episode by talking numbers.
Over 20,000 individuals
worldwide have been infected
with this novel Corona virus.
There's been 436 deaths worldwide,
with the huge majority
of them being in China.
There's only been a single
death outside of China
that's been in the Philippines.
In the US Currently, we have
11 cases, no fatalities.
Since we're talking about numbers.
I thought it would be
interesting to mention,
there are still 60 million
individuals on lockdown in China
this very moment, because
the Chinese government
is trying to do anything
and everything it can
to limit the spread of this virus.
Next, I thought we'd move
on to the designation
that the WHO released
last week saying that,
this is a global health emergency.
And when they did this, I saw
a lot of tweets come my way
of people critiquing my previous video
where I said that we should be alert,
not anxious and not panic and say,
"Well, how are you saying
this isn't a crisis
"if the WHO is labeling this
a global health emergency?"
Let's explain what the
WHO means when they say
something is a global health emergency.
Practically speaking, this
is gonna open up avenues
for networks of communication
between clinical sites,
research sites, lab sites,
it's going to unlock dollars
that can be spent for these networks.
On top of that, WHO is gonna
be able to hold countries
accountable for reporting
accurate numbers.
So we know what's going on internationally
and we can monitor the situation well.
It does not mean that they labeled it
a global health emergency
and we should panic.
In fact, it's the exact opposite.
They're taking steps to
prevent us from panicking
by making educated decisions and unlocking
much needed dollars to
help combat the situation.
Now moving on to the
designation by the CDC
of a national health emergency
here in the United States.
Again, this is not caused to panic.
It's obviously a reason
to be alert, not anxious.
I'm gonna repeat that
throughout the video.
But the reason they're
doing this is because
they're taking extra precaution and steps
to make sure that the
virus is not finding itself
here in the US.
Again, the huge majority of these cases,
the 20,000 cases are in China.
There's only 11 cases in the US
and we wanna keep that
number as low as possible.
What is the CDC doing?
Well, first and foremost,
we've increased screening to 20 airports,
we've also decreased the amount of flights
coming from China to the US.
And now if you're a foreign national,
meaning that you're not a US citizen,
and you're not a direct
relative of a US citizen,
if you're from China, or you've recently
visited China within the last 14 days.
You will not be allowed to
visit the US during this time.
On top of it, if you are a citizen
and you're coming back
from the area in China,
known as the Hubei province,
apologize if I'm mispronouncing that,
that's the area where the
virus first broke out.
Wuhan is the main city there,
you're gonna be held in
quarantine for 14 days.
So if you're coming from that city,
you're coming back to
the US and your citizen
or you're a family
member of a citizen here.
14 days quarantine just to me make sure
you don't have the virus
'cause the worst thing
that can happen is, if
you come from that area,
you don't know if you have the virus yet.
You go into the public,
you get a little sick,
you think it's a regular cold,
but it's really this novel, Corona virus.
You can get a lot of
people sick very quickly.
It is quite infectious,
much like the regular flu.
I'm gonna be talking about that in a bit.
As an interesting fact, the
last time we had this type
of quarantine period
happened in the 1960s,
with the smallpox epidemic.
For those of you who don't know,
we've eradicated smallpox,
thanks to vaccinations.
Which is why I'm very pro vaccinations,
obviously, not for just that reason.
But it's an important thing to know.
Something else the CDC is doing is
it's working in partnership with the FDA
to accelerate the approval process
for the testing that's
happening for the corona virus.
Which at this time can only
be done at CDC headquarters
in Atlanta, the whole
process really takes anywhere
from 24 to 36 hours, which
is quite a long time.
Hopefully, they're able to accelerate
this approval process
and get that process down
to somewhere like four to
six hours and get the test
spread outside of just the CDC lab.
That's the goal, it's
a lot easier to test it
in a Regional Hospital
sites than having to ship
the test to CDC every single time.
You may have seen some
headlines that call this
Corona virus outbreak and epidemic.
Those headlines are correct.
Some have said that it's
gonna be a pandemic.
You might be wondering,
what's the difference.
Well, an epidemic is a
spiking cases in a given area.
A pandemic is a worldwide
spread affecting many countries
with large numbers of people infected.
It has not yet been
ruled to be a pandemic,
by the World Health Organization,
or pretty much any health organization.
That being said, it's very possible that
it may turn into a pandemic.
But again, these are just definitions.
They don't really mean
anything for you and I
on day to day terms.
In fact, what I take
away from the possibility
of this becoming a pandemic,
and I certainly hope
that it doesn't continue to spread,
is that the countries that
are going to be affected
most by this disproportionately?
Are those that are the low
socio economic countries.
Ones that don't have a
modern healthcare system.
You think about certain
countries in Africa,
India, where there's
high rates of poverty.
You're gonna have individuals,
they're gonna be dying
from this simply because
they don't have access
to supportive care.
You may remember that
in the previous video
that I did on this virus, I
said that there is no treatment.
While there's no treatment,
we can definitely
give supportive care.
Just recently, the NIH
Director came out and said,
about 20% of these cases require
intensive care monitoring.
This is usually in the form
of mechanical ventilation.
And if you live in an area
where that's not available,
it's very possible that one in five people
will continue losing
their lives and certainly
low GDP countries will
not be able to build
1000 bed hospital in the
center of a city in 10 days
like they just did in China.
In fact, I believe that
center did just open today,
and its sole purpose is to help those
who are suffering with the Coronavirus.
Now let's move on to
things that we've learned
about this virus that we didn't
know from the first video.
Again, this is a lower respiratory tract
type of virus that your body
really needs to fend off
on its own.
The primary symptoms are fever, cough
and shortness of breath.
If you're experiencing
those and you've recently
visited China or you have some relatives
or friends that have visited China.
You should right away,
call your health provider,
let them know that you're
coming with these symptoms.
So they can prepare the waiting area
so as to not get any extra people sick,
especially those with
compromised immune systems.
New things that we've learned.
First, you may remember
that I mentioned something
about a symptomatic spread of this virus.
And it was something that
we were really concerned.
Let me explain that a bit further.
Those who are infected with the virus
but are not showing symptoms,
meaning that they don't have a fever,
cough or shortness of breath,
they can technically spread the virus.
We found out this to be true.
Now the cases where they
have spread the virus,
these asymptomatic individuals,
the cases have been rather mild.
Also, when we look back at
the history of past pandemics,
the main drivers of these viruses
have been those who have been ill.
In fact this virus is quite similar
in the way that it spreads
and the way that it gets
people sick to our
current Influenza virus.
And I bring that up specifically
to put things into perspective.
There's so many people that are worried
about the coronavirus
here in the United States.
There's 11 people with
zero people have died.
Just this flu season, there
have been more than 19 million
cases of the Influenza virus.
There have been over
180,000 hospitalizations
and over 10,000 deaths the Influenza virus
is what is a serious threat to our health.
And I see many patients
that have not yet gotten
their flu shot, get your flu
shot 'cause the Influenza virus
is a real threat and it's
imminent and it's here now.
We're gonna talk about how
coronavirus is gonna evolve
and what can happen
next steps but right now
you can protect yourself against Influenza
by getting vaccinated.
I'll be saying the same thing
if we do create a vaccine
in time for the corona virus as well.
And if you're interested
in ways you can stay safe
whether you're traveling or not.
I gave all those tips in my first video
definitely check that out.
Another interesting thing we've learned is
that this virus can spread
through the digestive tract,
meaning the fecal oral route.
So countries that have poor sanitation,
they could be facing
even a bigger challenge.
And currently, there is no
evidence that the Corona virus
this specific novel, Corona
virus can affect your pets.
And I say that because
there's been a ton of people
ordering these face
masks for their poor pets
thinking that they're
gonna protect them somehow
with these masks.
No, you're not and the WHO has been clear,
there's been no threat
to your pets at home.
Bear doesn't need a mask.
Speaking of face masks,
this has been a major
unintended consequence
of all of this news coverage
and hype and misinformation
about this virus that
people have bought so many
of these face mask that
they're running out of supply
for hospital systems.
Look, the reason we need
these surgical masks
the inexpensive ones
that go around the mouth
and wrap around the ears is
because if someone is sick
with the corona virus and
Influenza, Common cold
is good for patients to wear them
so that they don't get us sick.
It's meant for those who
are sick to not transmit,
not for you to stay safe.
There's no recommendation
from any organization
that you at home need one of these masks,
leave it to the professionals.
And I've seen some absolutely
crazy Instagram posts
of certain influencers posing
with some of these masks
showing how stylish they are.
This is medical equipment,
the fact that we're having
shortages of it puts medical
professionals at risk, and
that's absolutely crazy to me.
I wanna share a quick story of
something my patient told me
just a couple of days ago
that has me concerned.
So my patient who happens
to be Asian descent
told me that a couple of days
ago because they take the bus
every day from New Jersey
to New York for work.
People stopped sitting next to them
because they're worried
about this Coronavirus
'cause it comes from China.
And that's just really disappointing.
That type of xenophobia
doesn't belong here in the US.
We're better than that.
There's only 11 cases here in the US,
none in the New York, New Jersey area
and forgetting that we
should not be Xenophobic.
We should not be racist, we
should not be labeling anyone
that's never ideal look, you
know, I don't stand for that.
And I hope that we can all do better.
Finally, I wanna give a huge
shout out to all the doctors,
health professionals, first responders
that are working on combating this
novel Corona virus out there.
There's actually groups of researchers
traveling from the WHO to
Wuhan, China to help fight this
to learn more about it.
And we have to give them a huge thank you.
In fact, just the other day
we lost the first doctor
to this novel Coronavirus in Wuhan, China
and that's always unfortunate.
We as health care providers
put our lives on the line
every time something like this happens.
I think that's really important to say.
Finally, stay alert, not anxious.
Don't allow these media entities
that put scary headlines
out there to make you panic.
If you want quality information,
visit the CDC, WHO, NIH websites
or tune in and check out
my videos I'm gonna be delivering messages
from those sources and giving you the most
up to date information.
Remember this video
filmed February 3rd 2020.
If you wanna see my first
video on the Coronavirus,
click here and as always
stay happy and healthy.
(soft music)